Jack the last time we spoke we played a
game called past the pace oh then I was
watching the b-roll for this movie and I
saw some yes the pigs action happening
yes you bring it to every movie and what
do you guys think of the game I tried to
remember yeah pretty good okay I became
[ __ ] addicted to it yes this is really
like it's intense it's really yeah yeah
it's cool cuz it's all about restraint
exactly there's a method to it though I
feel like it's kind of us alright maybe
I just don't play enough to know there's
method in knowing when to stop yes yeah
there's a lot of crazy things that
happen in this movie but one of the
lines that really struck me is when
Father Flynn asks Darlene so why do you
do it because immediately in that moment
I'm like oh so like why do I do what I
love so I posed that question to you
guys is there any point in your career
where you ask yourself you know maybe
you were down and out why do I do it and
had an inspiring answer I kiss you like
this there are moments where you're so
like why am I doing this myself I mean
something well because I love it and
that's just it really when you love
something you take it for the good and
the bad I think that's that's my reason
yeah the movies I asked myself with my
music you know being the wings sometime
about to go on I've never sitting there
with my daughter who I performed with
some time and we're so nervous I was I
mean they get out in this thing what was
the problem yeah yeah that's why yeah
acting I feel like yeah I'm always I'm
freaked out you know days prior to the
scene tell your own
you're working it with an ensemble
that's great I imagine there must be
some nerves and freak out that I'm
excited to hear your answer for is if
you had the opportunity to swap roles
with anyone in this ensemble who would
you choose and why
I would like you'd be fun to play
Chris's part yeah yeah yeah that's what
I thought I know
oh yeah same thing yeah just yeah Billy
Lee would be kinda interesting yeah I
think it'd be interesting to have you to
swap switch okay that's it yeah all
right